nos partenaires y compris en Europe avec
vraiment sérieux
rendre les choses difficiles pour vous parce que
de nombreux pays
l'énergie nucléaire, eux aussi,
fermer oui elle a cherché à prendre ça
la source primaire n'est pas très puissante
il est clair que je suis en quelque sorte ici, il est intervenu là
l'allemagne transfère l'énergie satun
fermer le gaz que nous ne voulons pas acheter environ
qu'allez-vous chauffer avec du bois de chauffage, mais aussi avec du bois de chauffage
tu n'es pas obligé d'aller en sibérie, eh bien, c'est une blague
Bien sûr, mais c'est réel quand même.
le problème est de savoir comment le résoudre n'est pas facile
la tâche n'est pas et ils se compliquent